let's catch people up on what happened
with um jenna because she came on the
other week and she wanted to talk about
her and her girlfriends who
all uh purportedly are having a very
difficult time
with dudes
and they're all perfect you know they do
pilates they're hot you know you know we
heard the update and all that
uh so at the end of the show i invited
her to bring her friends on and um you
know chop it up and see what we could do
to be useful and she also went on your
show on
stereo afterwards and you're on every
night after this so you guys know where
to find uh moth but we'll mention again
towards that so what happened on the
show because um she emailed me and said
that they are not willing to come on
so it's funny because we actually spoke
a couple of times last week so we did
three different conversations we had the
one right after the show we had one on
tuesday with a couple of girls that i
know from stereo and renegade wingman
and then she and i did just a solo
partner show on
thursday i think which was a nightmare
but uh anybody can go back and listen to
those so you know i think part of it is
you can really you can really let stuff
fly on stereo there's not a lot of
censorship there's not a lot of you know
you can really kind of go at it that's a
lesser known platform so and i tend i
tend to grill people a little more
um
and i have
i think a little less patience than you
do when it comes to and you've done this
a lot obviously a lot more than i have
and for a lot longer but if you even go
back to
i think it was a couple mondays ago when
we had a couple women call in anastasia
and if you go back and watch the clips
when i'm asking her questions and it's
giving me really roundabout answers you
can see how annoyed i am it was it was a
carbon copy of that with jenna i mean it
looked
um
the talking points are the same
there's a lot of roundabout answers it's
a lot of
you know talking about very small
specific examples and having the
exceptions be the rule
um
so yeah i don't think that
her friends would be able to handle it
um
i don't think they're as good looking or
as valuable as she says or thinks they
are
yeah so
so that's something that i thought about
afterwards um
she was basically saying something along
the lines of her girlfriends were only
finding
uh nerds dorks incompetent men guys that
have never read a book before
right um there was no comment on
whether or not they were fit or not but
we know that women only date up like
they don't date down
so if they're dealing with what you know
we called losers at the time
then that means that they're basically
threes
yeah i mean it's it's funny because
this is something i was thinking about
as well is the idea of you know
people only ever talk about
mgtows and men that are now
i tend to think mgtows are men sent
their own way because essentially when a
guy goes to mctalist because he's not
gotten the results he wants from the
women he actually wants
so he's essentially said okay well i'm
never gonna get the one it's not that he
doesn't want those women anymore he just
made a conscious decision to stop
playing the game um fine but let's let's
call it what it is if you could you
would
uh now
those guys get branded as incels and
losers and black pill and this and that
but
you've got
women that are sent their own way as
well
so women that want i think they've been
sent their own way though which is
interesting and that was one of her main
points it was well you know a lot of
girls that i know
are perfectly fine staying at home with
their dogs and their boxed wine and
their netflix because they'd rather do
that than date losers it's like well it
doesn't mean they're happy right she
kept she
kept saying things like oh women are
happy to do that now no they're not
they just see that as a better
alternative for now let's see well if
all these women are so happy then why
are women prescribed antidepressants at
a rate five times higher than men over
the age of 40.
or why are they just so mad why are you
mad about the dating pool being scarce
if you're happier by yourself right so i
mean you wouldn't be complaining and
bitching about the lack of available men
and lack of good men if you really were
stoked to be at home with your dog in
your box wine
but mainstream media in the gynocentric
social order that we live in
say good for you you're a strong
independent woman you don't need any man
when in reality
they want that man who doesn't want that
so
i mean
nothing new you've seen any kind of
conversation with a woman on these kind
of platforms you've seen them all
uh the the most frustrating thing was
you know
somebody coming in and saying two plus
two equals five okay do we all agree
okay great now that we all agree let's
move on to this and i have to say no no
no no
two plus two equals four not five and
then she would throw a fade say oh you
bring that up all the time or you always
say that
we know when women are complaining about
uh men not stepping up or men being
players and men
banging around onto other women and
again we know that only the top 20 of
men are doing that
because they can but we also know that
most men are invisible to women so i
always i had to constantly step in and
correct her and say look
you're not talking about the majority of
men you're talking about the minority of
men and that would piss her off and
frustrate her and say oh you bring that
up every time it's like yes because i'm
not going to let you
make an argument
when the premise is two plus two equals
five it's just not how these things work
oh my goodness
hey guys
hey jenna
hey
this is gonna go viral now
no no i'm not here to argue i just
wanted to say i think everybody should
just kind of listen to
the conversations that we were having
um i think everyone will kind like i
think what you're saying is an
oversimplification so for example you
said that i said that women are happy
sitting at home um just drinking their
boxed wine and at one point in the
conversation i told you
women if you have to accept that you
know if you in this lifetime are not
going to find the partner that you want
you have to accept that you're going to
have to deal with what comes with being
an autonomous being which is sometimes
you're going to like being single
sometimes you're gonna hate it sometimes
you're gonna be sitting on your couch
with that wine and wish that you had
someone there but if you find that the
marketplace is not giving you what you
want you guys are already discussing
going to other countries
then you're going to have to deal with
what comes with not going with available
options
so
that is what i was saying yeah you
didn't say that at all though yeah i
didn't go back and listen to your
conversations and you didn't say that so
this is the first time yes i did yes i
did i quite literally at one point in
the conversation
the other thing you're leaving out of
this conversation is the last time moth
and i spoke he got upset because he was
basically being
gang-banged by people in the audience
sending in voice notes saying that you
know what's understood what i'm saying
you know what's going on and he stormed
off went into his own room
and then it started
hour-long conversation about what we
were discussing and apparently he was
heated so okay okay okay so if you guys
want to catch up on that drama you're
going to have to go to stereo and check
out the conversations for yourself jenna
why can't we get your girlfriends to
come on the show what are they afraid of
so basically they're afraid of like i'm
not going to kiss her ass but i'm a nice
guy like i'm not going to lie to them
richard you know what i to be quite
honest i was expecting the same kind of
conversation that i have with you
um i was expecting that when i went over
to stereo to have the conversation with
moth and at one point in the
conversation i asked him i said
i said what is the point of this
conversation because like you know and i
said it multiple times
the alpha males that i grew up with they
don't do a lot of negotiating or
discussing or debating with women so
i'm trying to figure out if we're having
this conversation is this about a
solution what solution are we going to
be having and he said at one point oh
this is just for entertainment value so
we're going to bicker for entertainment
value is that what we're doing i
wouldn't call it bickering i would call
it a discussion and a debate what what
part of the solution confuses you though
jenna because
i mean
like i've talked about the same concepts
over and over again people ask you know
different questions but they're all
very similar to stuff that i've dealt
with before right like there's probably
only 10 or 15
real questions that keeps popping up so
i've already kind of dealt with the
solutions for my audience as it as it
stands so what part of that is confusing
though to you and the girls there's not
okay so here's the other thing it's
about delivery there's nothing that you
say rich that i don't really understand
or disagree with at one point i flat out
said ladies we're too fat like a culture
where the women are size 16 is
unacceptable it's unattractive and
you're not going to force men to to find
this attractive
and and you and you also know that it's
unattractive because half of you if not
all of you are having sex with the
lights off
so stop it
but when we have this conversation i
haven't i haven't had sex with the
lights off my entire life the lights are
always on you see what i mean when i go
to work the lights are on right but you
see what happens when you take care of
yourself you tend to have a little more
pride in yourself and also you tend to
have firmer boundaries so right so when
you're talking to the ladies and you say
ladies you need to lose the weight like
what do you mean like you're talking to
the people like the women watching my
show are you talking about your
girlfriends like what are we talking
about here yes um so another thing so
about my girlfriends like it's a mixed
bag right and also as you
like i don't i wouldn't say that i have
a massive group of friends i have a lot
of acquaintances and then i have a few
friends within my friend group i have a
couple of women who are just drop dead
gorgeous
and like like literally just look like
they should be on a runway well by your
subjective stance yeah no no no i'm like
guys if we're all using the standard
that you know a non-pregnant adriana
lima is hot a megan fox is hot that is
the standard i'm using sports
illustrated as the standard not this new
okay fat girl whatever
um but
but i also have some girls in the group
who are
gelatinous and i have tried to speak to
them
i've tried and i have these
conversations which which ones are
complaining about dating the shitty men
the gelatinous ones or the megan fox
ones here's the funny thing the
gelatinous ones are actually having an
easier time with men because
most guys will stick their their
whatever in anything
so the hotter ones aren't even getting
approached
so you so you'll see so so the hot ones
are saying that they're dealing with
loser guys yes so even when they kind of
lower their standard for example like
one of them one of them she makes over
six figures so and here's the other
thing when people say this right okay um
to
be natural beauty is a wonderful thing
and one of the things that i i've said
to the guys i even said it in the
conversation with moth if you want a
lower cost of living and you want women
who are naturally beautiful
um usually
can i just pause you there for a second
i just want to go back to something that
you said
because you opened with she makes six
figures and then you went on to beauty
but
but what part of six figures is going to
appeal to men right it has nothing it
doesn't appeal to you guys at all what i
was the point i was trying to make about
beauty is that um
women who tend to make a lot of money
tend to spend money on beauty in a
different way than women who don't
really have a lot of money right so we
tend to gauge it by listen i go and i
get my nails manicured every two weeks i
get facials every two weeks plus gym
membership laser hair removal waxing all
we that's how we pile up our value when
it comes to dating we go what is it
costing me to be beautiful and what is
it costing me to put effort into myself
and why wouldn't i want a person who
does the same thing
that's that's what i mean
so
how old are these uh megan fox sports
illustrated girls um they're all on the
younger side so they're all 20 one is oh
i don't remember her age i think she's
like 25 26 another one is 31.
um the other one i don't remember
i
i'm i'm i'm thinking there's something
missing here jenna we started missing
because if you're describing a 25 year
old hot girl
what's the problem there's lots of like
is this chick in toronto
uh yes yeah there's lots of like tall
fit rich
funny competent captivating men in
toronto
yeah but the same thing with being a hot
woman it's the same thing as being a hot
man it's basic it's almost a dime a
dozen now there's so many hot like to be
a beautiful woman almost doesn't mean
anything anymore because
are they reasonable women though like
are they fun to be around or they like
yappy annoying ones with the exception
of one of them because
i don't
i don't hang out with her that much
because she's a buzzkill the rest of
them are actually kind of fun mm-hmm
okay
gotcha
well
i would love to have that conversation i
mean
you know what blows me away
i've been doing this show for
i don't know like 45 episodes on this
one plus the 104 episodes on the before
the train wreck i rarely get women that
call in i get women that watch the show
but i really get women that call in and
then you get other uh serious shows like
uh like kevin samuels almost exclusively
only talk to women
that was a rule
yeah only women call in oh yeah well if
i made that a rule
the show would only be like 40 minutes
long because i'd get no collins because
women don't want to talk to me
yeah well i actually um part of the last
conversation that i had with moth so
basically what happened is
um and again if you listen to the
conversations even though i disagreed
with things that he was saying i never
once personally attacked him i never
once kind of kind of went for the
jugular and implied that he was
worthless or he didn't have the
credentials to be speaking
um and maf you did do that you did do
that you flat out said to me did you
even graduate from college that's not
what i said and go back and listen to
the recording if you want jenna i
actually if you had a college degree
oh okay so and then semantics that's his
other thing and then yeah there you go
make stuff at least get it right
okay so do you see the kind of here's
the thing
here's the thing look we had two
conversations before that you were on
for me and jeremy for two and a half
hours on monday after the show then we
did another conversation the night after
and then you called me
on wednesday twice you tried to get me
to talk to you on stereo again and i was
busy and then i gave you a third try
where it's just about so like don't
position this as if we had one
conversation and i jumped down your
throat
yeah i think that one of the problems
that you're going to struggle with jenna
is that the angle that you generally
come at
talking about uh the sexes and
relationships and
the advice that you want to give men
comes from your experience working on
the phone
um
what do you do on the phone again you're
uh you're like a sex call in line or
something like that yeah phone sex line
yeah so like all of these nerds are like
calling you up because they want like
the attention of a woman you've got the
sultry voice knocked out of the park
which is perfect for what you're doing
and then you listen to these guys like
unload their [ __ ] on you
probably right you know talking about
their [ __ ] lives or their wives that
won't bang them or their girlfriend they
can never get over am i right
um yes i do listen to that of course but
that's not that that's not the only
place that i'm hearing it and then also
i would really encourage everyone to
listen to the conversation i believe
wholeheartedly that one of the big
issues that i have with both genders is
just a lack of decorum
i can disagree with a man and not rip
his head off and tell him that he's
worthless in a piece of [ __ ] or
worthless human being i didn't feel that
kind of that kind of respect when i was
talking him off when i was
talking speak any of those words or
anything of the source see here's what
you guys i need you guys to listen to
the actual conversation where all right
did i say you're worthless that i say
your appreciation
i didn't say that you said that i said
that you said that you were implying
that um that basically i'm uneducated
and then you also said i said well i
think at one point in conversation we
were saying something and i said moth i
wouldn't date you and you go yeah you're
too old for me anyway yeah like what is
this like what are these little childish
dicks what do you want from me what do
you mean what do i want from you all
right all right all right all right i'm
the one that's supposed to be an alpha
male mom how is it that i don't know why
you're getting so emotional right now in
real life all right
now we're going for the ad hom attacks
let's jenna cool your jets you know
moff thank you for thank you for filling
in
why you gotta go and do this [ __ ] to me
man dude i saw her in like the green
room so i'm like all right i'll bring
her in because you know well you know
she was listening i figured you know
what the hell no all right anyway i
think she likes you dude honestly i
think you guys make a cute couple dude
never in a million years i'll dig up the
picture that she sent and i'll send it
over to you if you want you know
that will make the connection
jenna i have no i will say this publicly
on this forum i have no beef with jenna
i don't think she and i are gonna ever
see eye to eye
on things yeah you will yeah uh if
again we're coming from two different
separate places she wants to throw out
homonyms out and attack my character and
all that and that's fine she totally can
um
that's okay all right no problem um i'm
gonna get to some of these call-ins and
well let me catch up with the super
chats thanks muff hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you